das video zeigt zwei polizisten in ihrem
dienstwagen um sie herum stehen sich
demonstranten dann ein klirren und die
scheibe des autos springt der polizist
am steuer duckt sich und hält sich die
arme über den kopf während sein kollege
schreit hau ab hau ab
[Musik]
die sehr großen jahre gezwungen hier
auch unterfertigt
[Musik]
hintergrund dieser attacke war eine
linken demo in berlin neukölln bei der
es zu massiven ausschreitungen kam
sprechen wir darüber mit bild reporter
matthias becker matthias du bist nicht
nur bild reporter sondern auch
ehemaliger polizist du hast die bilder
gesehen erzählt uns du hast den besten
einblick was empfindet ein polizist in
so einer situation ja man muss verstehen
wenn du auf einmal überall wirst von
demonstranten es gilt grundsätzlich
einsatz
der polizist hat auf der straße keine
freunde und jetzt kommt dieser schwarzem
ob ein
da hat man todesangst da ich saß in
einem auto
da hat das auto hat gebrannt nicht bekam
im mai ab da hilft nur eins der polizist
nennt das sammeln der tiefe des raumes
das heißt man zieht den blauen das ist
der stift damit er das blaulicht und das
martinshorn angeht und dann wird einfach
nur besucht ein ausweg in dem moment als
man um zählt ist von dem mob überrannt
wird das auto das einsatzfahrzeug zu
einer tödlichen mausefallen man kommt
dann nicht mehr weg sagt dass gerade
schon man kommt da nicht mehr weg was
tut man dann am besten man zieht im
blauen mit blaulicht martinshorn an und
versucht irgendwo eine lücke zu finden
zwischen den demonstranten den
fußgängern passanten und man muss da
ganz schleunigst weg das ist leib und
leben in gefahr für sich aber auch für
die streifen begleiter
du bist ja wie gesagt ehemaliger
polizist kannst du dich an irgendeiner
situation erinnern die vergleichbar war
das waren ja in den 90er jahren die
hausbesetzer szene die ich sehr schwer
waren
die haben 40 mal 40 schwerer kilo
schwere betonplatten aus dem vierten
stock geworfen auf polizeibeamte
die sind mit drei spitzen durch die
stahlwände dann hier dieses
einsatzfahrzeug hat weder geht dann noch
sicherheitsfolie dh das ist alles
unterstützt der wollte vielleicht nur
den querverkehr rausnehmen dass da keine
autos in diese
nein fahren sie sind eigentlich zum
schutz der demonstration dort eingesetzt
und während attackiert das hatten wir
früher auch schon so dass dann mitunter
am 2 mit muttern und schrauben
geschossen kugeln einsatzfahrzeuge
durchschlagen haben das kennen wir schon
aus den 80er jahren ja die bilder wenn
man sie sieht ihr erinnern ja auch stark
an die ersten bei dem uns kann man
mittlerweile so weit gehen und sagen
dass randalierer den kauf den tod von
polizisten sogar in kauf nehmen
ja unbedingt
sie müssen ihr handeln absehen und jeder
der einen 3 spielt der eine zwille
stahlkugeln verschießt oder molotow
cocktails auf polizei nach auf menschen
wenn dafür nicht vergessen da steckt ein
mensch hinter dieser uniform und dieser
mensch will hier bei diesem
einsatzfahrzeug wer will eigentlich nur
die demonstration absichern dass da also
nichts passiert nicht und ein verwirrter
autofahrer auf einmal diese
demonstration reinfährt und diese
menschen die steine einwerfen und derart
massiv polizeibeamte angehen der nimmt
letztendlich auch den tod von menschen
in kauf